les vérités du cœur de Pascal sont là
pour nous rappeler quelque chose de
fondamental c'est que ce qui est le plus
vrai est en même temps ce qui est le
plus au fond de nous et ce qui est au
fond nous est en même temps ce qui est
parfois le plus difficile à entendre
parce que le cœur ne peut pas nous
parler plus fort qu'il le fait déjà
lorsqu'on entend plus la voix du cœur le
problème ne vient peut-être pas du cœur
mais de notre capacité à l'entendre et
pour l'entendre il est parfois
nécessaire de retirer ce qui le couvre
de retirer le bruit qui nous empêche de
l'entendre le bruit de notre mental le
bruit de nos doutes le bruit de nos
peurs car alors nos peurs apparaîtront
pour ce qu'elles sont des ombres des
ombres que l'on prend à tort pour des
objets réels des ombres qui ne sont que
des fantômes sans pouvoir et qui
disparaîtront dès qu'on laissera entrer
un peu de lumière